I think it's the recovery still unstable
and we need more coordination and
cooperation because how during the
immediate crisis the seams coordination
was well we call the main task at a time
to rescue the banking system and then
stimulate the economy by this later
stage the recovery process seems now
there are big differences force in the
u.s. deal to the high unemployment
sluggish demand so the government
decided to take you know quantitive
easing monetary policy and then but
thats increase the government's deficit
and we weaken the US dollar but in
Europe because of sovereign debt public
debt so they have too tight the public
spending and and so they see the major
two economies are quite different and
also China emerging economies they are
their economy generally on the high
agenda but they need to control their
inflation and worried about the more
money will load into their economies so
at this moment how you know there are
the other issues they have to cooperate
closely so how to coordinate this kind
of great differences
global economy forces rebalancing
unchanging of the model and then reform
of international monetary system and so
all this need of strong coordination
seeing from Seoul g20 that they
generally agreed on but but also you see
the differences and the key issue is how
to improve you know where they
coordinated actions so I think that's a
great challenge but among the emerging
economies they are doing well but they
have a big big challenge how to
restructure their economy moving to a
new model energy saving and clean
economy and a new model of consumption
and all this also inclusive government
and to take care of more you know poor
populations to let majority benefit from
economic development